Bueller Bueller American education is
rife with grand policy proposals that
have turned into bureaucratic Fiasco's
from school turnarounds to the Common
Core this is big our reform big our
reform takes the hot idea of the moment
invests it with grand enthusiasm and
then tells doubters and skeptics that
they better get on board or get the heck
out of the way I first saw this stuff up
close a quarter century ago when I was
teaching high school in Baton Rouge
Louisiana at the time the hot new reform
in the state was a teacher evaluation
system the idea was laudable make sure
teachers are doing their jobs well the
solution a checklist of the hundred and
thirty-odd items that administrators
dragged into classrooms it was nonsense
good schools are intensely human places
they are formed by thousands of good
judgments on the part of teachers that
they make every day this is why grand
bureaucratic fixes tend not to make a
big difference for schools this is the
problem with big our reform and it's why
there are better ways to give our kids
the schools they deserve to learn more
about my take on the problem of big our
reform check the links in the
description below also let us know what
other topics you'd like a EEI scholars
to cover in 60 seconds